straight ahead on Long crime daily
The Alex Jones defamation trial I'm
probably gonna have to take the fifth
not because I've done anything wrong but
because she's saying she'll find me or
put me in jail if I answer these
questions truthfully this is a trap but
I'm walking into this trap because I'm
willing to face my accusers the
defendant takes the stand in his now
second civil case after calling the 2012
Sandy Hook shooting a hoax plus a
political dispute turns deadly when a
man allegedly admits the hitting and
killing a teenager with his car while
intoxicated and a suspect is named and
charged after a father and his toddler's
son are found dead in Texas then later
the Ohio trial of George Wagner IV we
were told of two victims
um at the initial notification by the
time we all get there to Pike then
that's when we learned if we had eight
total victims with four different crime
scenes jurors here from an agent who
processed the third crime scene in The
Pike County Massacre long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone so long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckby defendant Alex
Jones takes the stand in the Sandy Hook
defamation trial where family members of
the victims sue the info wars host over
comments he made following the 2012
Sandy Hook shooting
the conspiracy theorist appeared inside
the courtroom for the first time in his
Connecticut defamation trial which stems
from The Commons Jones made after the
Sandy Hook elementary school massacre
back in December of 2012 when the
internet show host called the incident a
hoax put on by crisis actors in order to
push gun control this lawsuit brought on
by families of the victims of the
shooting and a first responder is the
second of three suits heading to trial
drones was already deemed liable in each
case in Texas and Connecticut now
separate juries will determine how much
he has to pay the plaintiffs on Thursday
the plaintiff's attorneys call Jones to
the stand he was confronted at the start
of the day about his previous condemning
of the judicial system and question
about calling the judge a tyrant
this trial started and you've been
you've been calling it a kangaroo court
yourself right yes right and you've
called this judge a tyrant correct yes
okay and you actually use that word a
lot with your audience you call people
tyrants don't you
only when they act like it this is the
Tyrant pictured here that you've been
telling the government is about right
right I thought you were asking me again
about about the image or about me
believe this is tyrannical
this is
this picture right here that's Judge
Bellis correct yes Laser's coming out of
her eyes correct yes that's who you've
been referring to as a tyrant to your
audience correct yes okay and you refer
to tyrants
um to your audience a lot right
some right tyrants are people who are
um going to oppress others and strip
them of their freedoms correct
that's a common definition right and
you've not just
called George Bell as a tyrant
but you said that this whole thing
What's Happening Here is part of a plot
isn't it you're actually motion and let
me no not the whole thing I think the
series
Jones has been in Connecticut this week
preparing to take the stand he's held
multiple news conference outside of the
courthouse bashing the proceedings
happening inside
here's the problem
the judge says I can't say I'm innocent
the judge says I can't talk about this
being a political trial when all it is
is political and they've been nothing
but political they put up a picture of a
magazine I put out saying Obama wants
your guns and then when my lawyer said
see this is political she said I will
sanction you if you say that again this
is not political they get to be
political and then pretend that that
this isn't political so since when is
someone not allowed to say they're
innocent
said she will sanction me if I say I'm
innocent so when their lawyers ask me
questions I'm between a rock and a hard
place if they ask me questions and I
truthfully answer no I didn't make money
off Sandy Hook no I didn't
premeditatedly put it out no I'm not the
first person to question it I followed
what the internet was saying and
covering she will then sanction me so
I'm probably going to have to take the
fifth not because I've had anything
wrong but because she's saying she'll
find me or put me in jail get my answer
these questions truthfully this is a
trap
joining us today is legal analyst
Richard schoenstein and co-host Terry
Austin Richard objections flew quickly
and frequently a lot about opening the
door can you break down the argument and
why it went the way that it did
absolutely you know Alex Jones has an
endless stream of nonsense he wants to
tell you about on the courthouse steps
but also in the courtroom he wants to
testify about how this is all political
witch
but he already waived the liability
portion of this case by failing to
participate in Damages he's cut off from
testifying about a lot of that his one
hope is if the other side opens the door
by asking questions that would permit
him to give those kind of answers in
response so far the judge is saying no
so far the judge is keeping tight
control of this trial end of the
testimony he's going to give
Terry Jones seems to distinguish between
what he has said and what people in his
organization has posted so can he be
liable for what his contractors post
well one could argue that the comments
by either his employees or his
subcontractors could be imputed to him
he's at the top of that org chart he's
responsible for his brand he's
responsible for his messages and he's
fully aware that his employees speak on
his behalf they create those images they
talked about the image of the judge he
called the judge a tyrant they knew he
called the judge a tyrant they created
that poster they put the lasers in the
eyes and they did it because they knew
that's what he wanted to do he didn't
say don't do it and I definitely think
that they could easily impute what the
employees are saying to what you know
Alex Jones is is saying outside the
courtroom well we'll see all these kids
continues as I think Alex Jones and
others may continue to testify and in
celebrity news Los Angeles County has
agreed to pay more money to Vanessa
Bryant's co-plaint tip Chris Chester who
lost two loved ones in the 2020 deadly
helicopter crash which also killed NBA
great Kobe Bryant and several others
Chester has now been awarded nearly 20
million dollars after he and Brian sued
the county over gruesome photos from the
crash which killed his wife Sarah and
their daughter Peyton both Chester and
Brian sue the county for an invasion of
privacy alleging First Responders use
their personal phones to share photos of
their deceased family members the
settlement money includes the 15 million
dollar verdict which was awarded to
Chester last month at trial in which
Brian was also awarded a 15 million
dollar payout in exchange for accepting
a higher judgment amount Chester has
agreed to resolve all pending litigation
or future claims by him or his family
also in celebrity news or lawyers for
Atlanta music executive Shaka Zulu who's
charged with murder after a June
shooting left one person dead hold a
press conference speaking out in
response to the charges Ludacris's
longtime manager was one of three men
shot in the June 26 incident one of the
men artez Benton died of his injuries
investigators later identified Zulu as a
suspect charging him with murder
aggravated assault possession of a
firearm during her crime and simple
battery Zulu turned himself in and was
released the same day after posting a
two hundred thousand dollar bond in
Thursday morning's news conference
Zulu's attorneys explained his side of
the story saying a friend of Benton's
approached Zulu pulled out a gun and
then and they got into a confrontation
they said Zulu was trying to de-escalate
the situation and defending himself when
Benton got shot his attorneys said there
was even an eyewitness at the scene that
can corroborate Zulu's story Zulu's
attorneys criticized Atlanta police for
not bringing charges against the other
people involved in the shooting
still out on Law and crime daily a
suspect is in custody in Houston after
her father has gunned down his car is
stolen and his toddler is found dead
hours later in the back seat
but first a man accused of vehicular
homicide is released on bond after
Shannon Brandt allegedly killed a North
Dakota teenager over a political dispute
[Music]
welcome back to the founder and CEO of
my pillow is soon the FBI after claiming
the agency seized his cell phone while
he was waiting at a Hardy's drive
through in Minnesota in the suit filed
this week Mike Lindell directly names
the FBI director the U.S attorney
general and the United States the suit
claims the feds had no authority to
detain the end question in doubt against
his will and that they violated his
first fourth fifth and sixth amendment
rights the justice department is
investigating Lindell over potential
identity theft and a suspected voting
equipment breach in Colorado's Mesa
County investigators say the cell phone
seizure was to search for records or
information connecting Lindell to Mesa
County election clerk Tina Peters who's
been indicted for an alleged scheme to
breach voting machines during the 2020
election Lindell also faces lawsuits
brought by two voting machine companies
over his claims that they rigged the
2020 election
a North a North Dakota man is facing
homicide charges but was released out on
bond for allegedly killing a teenager
with his car after a political dispute
41 year old Shannon Brandt is charged
with felony vehicular homicide for
allegedly hitting 18 year olds Kaylor
Ellison with his car earlier Sunday
morning Brent reportedly told Troopers
he felt threatened by Ellison and
admitting to hitting the team with his
car because he had a political argument
with him and believed he was part of a
republican extremist group Brent was
given a breathalyzer test when he was
arrested at his home and registered
above the legal limit of 0.08 a brand
was released Tuesday from jail on a
fifty thousand dollar Bond after
pleading with the judge that he was not
a Flight Risk his next court appearance
for an arraignment is scheduled for
October 11th
so your brand seems to be suggesting
this vehicular homicide was in
self-defense and over a political
argument no less at this point is that a
working defense here you know Brian I
don't see that as a viable self-defense
argument it's difficult to say that
killing a pedestrian with a car could
actually be considered self-defense even
if Grant thought the victim was calling
people and they were going to attack him
and he was getting ready he had an
opportunity to drive away and based on
all of the reports so far it doesn't
appear that he tried to get away it
appears as though the opposite was the
case that the victim was trying to get
away the victim was not posing any
immediate danger and So based on all
that I don't think that that's going to
be a good self-defense argument for
Brent yeah I would agree as well Richard
on top of that Brand's baec was above
the legal limit but that was done hours
after the incident so is that going to
harm any potential defense that he puts
forward
yeah I think it will Brian I mean being
drunk generally doesn't help you in any
defense to a criminal charge and it's
not going to help here because if he's
trying to say he acted in self-defense
his judgment about needing to act self
in self-defense was impacted by the
intoxication so that's not going to help
him whatsoever and it doesn't exonerate
him it doesn't offer him an additional
defense to having you know run the guy
down so I think it's a problem it's
certainly not a help yeah alcohol tends
to kind of enrage people and this seems
like a killing out of Rage it's
something prosecution will probably try
to really drive home well coming up on
lawn crime daily a Houston father is
gunned down and killed his two-year-old
son found dead hours later in his stolen
SUV now a suspect is in cussing plus we
head to the courtroom in a Pike County
where jurors are taken through a third
crime scene in the trial of defendant
George Wagner IV
foreign
[Music]
welcome back a man is in custody and
charged with two counts of murder after
a father and his young son were killed
in Houston earlier this week police
released the identity of the suspect
boldland Lee fodero earlier Thursday
morning after an investigation into the
deaths of his father and his
two-year-old son Micah led to his arrest
Michael essien was gunned down on
Tuesday at a gas station investigators
say ifodaro stole his SUV with his
two-year-old son inside the car was
found hours later just a couple of miles
away but police were too late Essie and
son was left alone inside the hot car
for hours he was found dead from what
officials believe was heat exhaustion
fedaro was reportedly known has
reportedly known asean for 30 years as
he leaves behind a wife and two other
children including a week old baby
hidario made his first appearance in
court Thursday and is being held on a
750 thousand dollar Bond
is charged with the death of two people
including a two-year-old but they died
in very different ways so how will the
charges differ in Prosecuting him
well they are related homicides
obviously but I do think the charges are
going to be very different obviously
authorities are still just Gathering all
the information but based on the
information so far from the witnesses
the surveillance cameras it does appear
that the suspect intentionally obviously
shot and killed the father but as far as
the baby's concerned I'm assuming he
knew the baby was in the car and he left
the child in the car I think there could
be murder charges there could be you
know manslaughter charges perhaps
because it might not have been
intentional but either way I think when
they find the suspect he really should
be held accountable for these horrible
deaths yeah they could also probably
throw a felony murder at him for the
death of the child but Richard in New
York we have leandro's laws for driving
while intoxicated with a child's
passenger you can face higher penalties
so do you think we could see new laws
coming from the death of the
two-year-old victim in a similar
situation here
it might be a good idea I mean this is a
perfect example carjackings are a
problem in this country from time to
time and they not only cause the obvious
harm of taking the car but they can
create uh adverse consequences like this
horrible tragedy he probably didn't know
there was someone in the back seat and
he was leaving him but because he
committed a crime he was creating the
opportunity for something bad like that
to happen and I think maybe we do need
some statutes that address that yeah
well we'll see how this case continues
again just the recent arrests we will
follow the story on Law and crime daily
when we come back testimony in Ohio's
Pike County Massacre case moved on to
the third crime scene at defendant
George Wagner the fourth stands trout
for several charges including murder
[Music]
welcome back to Modern crime daily uh
suspect turns himself in days after a
home invasion of an elderly couple in
Virginia is caught on camera take a look
[Music]
hey Bobby
[Music]
man
nothing
[Music]
oh man
please say the men in the video are
Mitchell Boney Jr and Tyree Demond Boney
Jr the suspect stole only a wallet and a
safe days later one of the suspect
micheloboni Jr turned himself in he's
charged with armed robbery use of a
firearm abduction and conspiracy to
commit a burglary
and switching to Ohio where a testimony
moves on to a third crime scene in The
Pike County Massacre trial of defendant
George Wagner IV jurors heard from a
former investigator with the Ohio Bureau
of criminal investigation first thing
Thursday morning shortly after the
defense was denied a second motion for a
mistrial in just as many days over the
bloody photos out of each crime scene
and autopsy photos being shown in court
this comes as George Wagner IV is being
tried for the execution-style murders of
the Rhoden and Gilly families back in
2016. George along with his brother
Jacob and their parents Billy and Angela
are all accused of having a part in the
killings which investigators say stemmed
from a custody dispute involving a child
Jake had with Hannah Gilly on Thursday
former BCI agent Brian White took the
stand to testify about processing the
third crime scene the trailer where Dana
and her two children Hannah May and
Chris Rhoden Jr were killed he told
jurors in detail about the three
bedrooms where each body was found as
they were shown photos of each victim he
described the graphic images shown on
Dana's body
tell us what that item is uh that's item
number six which is what we just saw so
that was the pillar that was covering
her face and um all that documenting is
when the pillow came off of her face uh
documenting what the the uh pillow
looked like there appears to be
um you know obviously blood yes but then
um other material that is kind of more
in the center of that photo can you tell
us what that is blood tissue
um and that's very common in gunshot
wounds to have tissue or or other matter
brain matter whatever
can ooze out of the actual bullet holes
themselves so that's what we've got
going on there or the mouth any opening
nose ears you name it okay but there was
not
in bullet holes that went through that
pillow no there were not
all right Richard schoenstein the
defense moved through a mistrial again
this morning why so many and did this
one have any Merit
well why so many is because there's so
much gruesome evidence in this case
there's an endless barrage of
photographs and other graphic evidence
of these crime scenes and they don't all
prove that this defendant is tied to the
murders at all so at some point the
prejudicial value clearly outweighs the
probative value of this
um this particular motion was probably
proper denied be because it hasn't gone
over the edge yet but you know
defendants are going to keep making
these motions there's no cost to making
a mistrial motion and their objective
here is to either get an acquittal or to
create appellate issues that would allow
a conviction to be overturned they're
going to tend to make every motion they
can they're going to pile up the
mistrial motions even if none of them in
and of themselves are meritorious enough
to carry the day all right Richard
thanks buddy that's kind of like the big
picture of this especially looking
beyond for the appeals so Terry let's
dig down a little deeper the defense
made at least one objection I think that
Richard kind of touched on that seems
really interesting why show evidence of
a crime scene where you can't prove the
defendant was there could there be
grounds for an appeal or is there
something else that's going on here
well you know I think that evidence I
agree with Richard is not enough for a
mistrial and I think that evidence is
not enough for an appeal but it does
make sense it's a very reasonable
objection I think that it could be more
prejudicial than probative but I think
it is related he is also charged with
conspiracy and tampering with evidence
so showing those crime scenes is very
relevant all right we'll see how this
goes both with this case and potential
appeals thank you Richard and Terry and
thank you for joining us here on lawn
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]